so we already watched Andrew Tate now he
actually has a younger brother oh got a
bunch of hoes too a bunch of money so we
can just watch him and you can give your
thoughts if you call a woman every name
you want to call her and spit in her
face
she's gonna forget about you within a
day she's going to be like you know what
all that nice time I spent with Tristan
he showed his true colors tonight that's
who he really is yeah you're gonna make
that lasting bad impression I always
like to leave with a lasting good
impression and also you have to
understand that when you want to be a
playboy in a certain city so I live in
Bucharest Romania girls will ask girls
who slept with me been with me spend
time and they go what's Tristan like uh
such a nice guy I had such a good time
with him he just you know maybe he
wasn't ready for something serious right
he was a bit of a cheater but he was
always wonderful exactly exactly what
they won't say is you know he's like
yeah exactly he's a psycho he threw me
out the house right you know because
there's no advantage to doing that now I
live in Eastern Europe but especially in
the Western World you know you throw a
girl at her house your house and upset
her too much you might just me to your
ass so all these tough guys out there
who want to treat women bad I I would
advise against it in every single way
does he sound like a misogynist no no no
no he doesn't no he's going with
different girls and he's a gentleman
treats them right now he's honest but
he's not saying he's married I mean you
know it would be different faces there's
a whole different uh subject but if he's
treating girls nice women nice when it
goes on dates he should treat them nice
and he should have a good reputation and
if they do if he does fit in their face
like he says and whatnot you drop him
like a hot potato go on your way that's
right you know that's it you know what
it does sound like he's out breaking
hearts though you know you go out you
treat all these women nice they think
they think that they're special and
really they're not it's just how he
treats everybody yeah so it is he's he's
kind of playing with their heads yeah
which which in itself is not gentlemanly
in my opinion but then again he's saying
girls are asking all the other girls
about him how he treats them so the
girls you know he's sleeping with knows
he's sleeping with everyone else anyway
so that makes you think you're gonna be
different I don't think he's giving
girls do girls do think that they're
going to be different ones you know that
right right but it doesn't sound like
he's given the impression that he's
letting them know that there he has more
commitment to them I don't think I think
they know he does not have a commitment
to them that he's just he goes with them
and but he treats them good yeah this
girl's ass how is he when you slept with
him he's got his PhD what are you gonna
do that's his yeah that's their problem
do you know what PhD stands for ladies
no it's pimp and hoes degree okay
for guys to do it that's true right all
right but I don't think he's doing
anything wrong I I really I give him a
good knock on this one I don't think
he's doing I think he's doing way better
than nine percent of the guys that stick
with girls and don't treat them right so
uh yeah yeah he ghosts a couple of them
he's talking to a bunch of girls and he
does
the only kind of Revenge that you can
get on a woman is this say goodbye
politely keep working hard increase your
value as a man wait three years four
years six years 11 years and you know
this story the 11 year story and wait
till you are the man and she's just now
some chick 28 29 and she's like Tristan
you know it should have always been you
then you can either tell her no or break
her heart again then you win that's the
only way to get revenge Sinatra said the
best revenge is massive success so some
girl dumps him right instead of sitting
and feeling sorry for himself he's
turning around going you know what I'm
gonna go and I'm gonna be the best
goddamn guy anybody any woman could ever
want and 10 years later she she happens
to run into him at the gas station
buying cigarettes or whatever and he
happens to be driving a Bugatti and and
looking good and has it all that's the
best revenge and it's the same for a
woman too if a guy breaks your heart I'm
like what is it like what does a woman
do she goes and like gets in better
shape or something no she might have
been in good shape to begin with I went
out like two best friends there's a
thousand there's a thousand things yeah
I wanna I broke up with Danny and I went
out with his two friends
roommate Johnny dalello oh yeah
I can't think of his name he lived right
on 30th no uncle Danny was a great guy
he looked like a movie star what did
Johnny to level look like yeah but it
didn't matter if it's a trash did the
trick not much it broke up there living
together it couldn't have been yeah it
was he still his friends after that evil
no no
later on
Santa was this just a piss off uncle
Danny because you really liked her menu
yeah what do you do to deserve that he
can hold me up I may believe he was my
other boyfriend Richie
wait Uncle Dan wait wait let's back up
Uncle Danny called the store and said he
was his fella Richie that I was going
out with from Chiefs if I'm in my
girlfriend Marion I used to go out there
on Saturday she had a friend Richie and
we still double dating so he found out
he was going out Richie he calls the
store when the candy store and he said
he was Richie so I answered the phone it
was him
so what was he trying to do by
pretending to be Richie just to see if
you were there 18 16. she wanted to go
out again I wouldn't talk to him
what did he do that you just he was with
another girl
[Applause]
I got even I'm going out with all your
best friends right now I'm not even did
that make you feel better yep and it
made him it made him pissed and made him
there my sister is a hoe
maybe that girl has absolutely no
interest in him whether he has money or
not so all the work he thinks he's doing
to get revenge on her she couldn't kill
us but there's always one he's talking
about the one yeah and so you know what
and it took back to Ann Sansa it made
them it it pissed him off and it
straightens his ass out right and how
many years have you married to him 62 62
years of marriage after the other day
was 63 so 64. well it would have been 64
November 1st yeah that's when I got
married yeah
there is the case where he's doing
awesome thinking boy she's gonna come
around and maybe she couldn't kill us
then when I say that weed is one of the
most dangerous drugs of all because it
halts your ambition it stops you from
being unhappy with your current crap
situation you play a PlayStation you eat
your pizza you smoke you read that's a
good day that's a bad day for me and
it's a bad day for you if you minus the
weed I think it's a horribly Dangerous
Drug and people who'd smoke it really
really do need to stop and every single
time this comes up it's well Elon Musk
don't say Elon Musk to me he doesn't
Advocate weed he doesn't even say he
smokes weed he took a puff once on one
podcast ever now if you're gonna use
what's called an argument from Authority
at me an argument of authority is well
this person's rich and important and
blah blah so he's a weed guy one he's
not a weed guy two if you're gonna rely
on arguments from Authority the the the
smarter richer person saying something
about weed means he's right that I'm
right and you're wrong because I'm rich
and I'm smart and you're broken you're
dumb and you smoke weed so you just
admit it I'm right well I I don't
believe in wheat I don't think it should
be legalized it does deaden your your
way of thinking or your sharpness I mean
they say this song and it leads to
further drugs and normally when you're
on weeks not everybody you start with
the weed and then you go with the pills
and then you go with the heroin most
teenagers start off with marijuana then
they decide to see if heroin has any
kick it does sometimes it only takes a
few days to find out they can't leave it
alone well I don't know about all that I
I agree like weed's not good because it
halts your ambition but the gateway drug
thing I don't think it's as much because
what are you more likely to do drugs
when you're drunk or when you're when
you're high on Weeds you know
I mean I guess you guys wouldn't you
wouldn't know I I believe alcohol is a
far more uh dangerous gateway drug than
weed weed just makes you go I feel good
I'm cool here before doing alcohol
really impairs your judgment where
you're going to be more likely to have
sex to to try something else
why do you have to answer one with the
other really leads to yeah it's people
young people start don't go right take a
puff take then they'll take another two
Puffs tomorrow goes on and then all of a
sudden it's not enough then they go to
something else to fill that's not that's
what we're saying we're contradicting
that and saying no it's alcohol that
does that alcohol is the Gateway right
yeah all right I'm curious just curious
by by show of hands everybody at the
table who smoke pot
I love you so much more I did oh Jordan
a little Pike
Lorraine's off camera Lorraine so okay
listen no no I'm asking I gotta tell you
I turned 80 and I said I really want to
do something bold bold
so
Peggy I didn't call you up I was saying
yes
it doesn't matter it doesn't yeah you
call me before you came here
bear America was there we were hashing
it around I said yeah she takes out a
little purse and this little pipe and
she says I I have it so I said so okay
and she likes it and I whatever I did
and she says no you have to hit it
[Music]
well I didn't know that because I don't
smoke baby says take a hit yes so now I
take it and I just want I inhale what
was it like I don't remember but she
fell asleep do you want it guys I have a
joint do you guys want to yeah
if you do I wouldn't do it when I was
with them I was there I wouldn't yeah
but Bubba's going uh-uh anyone else want
a tripod for the first time just saying
something I did it I did it I think I'm
not sorry I did it was it it was a fun
experience oh God no I think that weed
is the most dangerous just for
entrepreneurs because for a lot of
people that work regular jobs you can go
to your nine to five and in that off
period the way their brains are wired is
you don't have to do work like that's
your time to relax right so if you smoke
then it's not as important but if you're
an entrepreneur where time is really
money and like every single hour you're
wasting you could be doing something
productive then smoking Paul to you
because that's once you smoke pretty
much the rest of the day you're useless
and then you're waking up more tired and
if you're if you're making your own
money and he breaks the say yes it works
very hard yeah but exactly he works a
job so then when he's not working
he can relax and smoke
but if he's an entrepreneur we're during
that off time you don't have off I mean
I don't like it but yeah
yeah but you could work but again like
he says your heat comes home from work
and not him personally I don't mean he
comes home from work and that's it his
day is done you see what I'm saying
right he's not doing anything else to
produce anything else it's almost like
the video game Gamers right I think it's
awesome it's just a Time filler too it's
the same thing as why people scroll on
their phones all day to occupy their
minds while you watch TV while you smoke
just you can we're we're all in it you
think that it that it just that it just
kind of helps you right so yeah
but the reason I asked the question who
has smoked because everybody's got very
strong opinions about what it leads to
but on one of the five of you at the
table has admitted has admitted 50 years
ago okay
all right all right let me finish you're
right okay okay so two with the table
have tried it and Frankie D'Angelo told
me you tried it once too you can say
wherever I believe Frankie he's not
alive we were in Frankie we were at his
friends and they gave it to me and I
went like this and I put it down
yeah
I hate when you're asked a question I
would know about one thing and they
bring something up like you said well
liquor is former we're not talking about
liquor okay well take a look around but
but I'll tell you this again one two
three four five of you two of you
admitted one's been accused of smoking
pot and everybody's got real strong
opinions about what it leads to you
don't know because you don't truly have
experience
and I am telling you as somebody that
has you know played around pot was never
the thing that led me to something else
pot was the thing that sat me on the
couch and made me watch this movie watch
TV that's what he's saying but you're
saying it's a gateway drug that makes me
go I want a pillow I want to do a line I
want to do this
that's what I'm hearing here no did they
maybe go to bed and nobody came with me
what you tried it it didn't make you go
now I want to try can I get anybody get
a lunch anybody got something that's it
like your mother said someone that
smokes it after a while it doesn't do
the trick for you and then they go on to
something stronger it's a proven fact
it's not I think it's just propaganda
from the War on Drugs that's what they
say and now those two sisters
let's do research I'll do research okay
they're finding the pots uh signs
written brand new babies babies that are
born parents that smoke pot when they
have babies they're finding traces of
pot in a new horse you guys were born
in your vodka in your face yeah
I was born she didn't drink that she
only ever drained
with it turns her into a drunk yeah
my brother went to Slovakia he calls me
and said something amazing has happened
I want some money in the casino like
really how much he said 5 000 Euros am I
[ __ ] good we need to pay the rent got
these payments to make on the car
insurance and we need the money good
take that 5 000 Euro don't go back to
the casino he comes home I said where's
the cash he goes I don't have any cash I
bought this watch I was pissed we need
to pay the rent we need to pay this how
can we just spend it on and watch what's
that what's going to do for you and you
said to me don't worry we'll make more
money and I completely forgot about that
until six years ago now we were walking
to Westfield shopping center and you
bought your Hublot watch and then you
take this one off give it to me and you
said Tristan do you remember when I said
we'd make more money and I was like you
[ __ ] we did this is a reminder
of Andrew's unshakable self-confidence
and a reminder to myself to remember I
am one of the tape Brothers I'm not the
guy who's gonna be crying about oh we
can't pay our bills no no I'll make more
money there's something I want I'll make
more and that has been my attitude ever
since that that argument in fact that's
why I don't take this off a good message
or being irresponsible I think he's
being irresponsible you've got bills to
pay but I understand because I love
jewelry
certainly well you know what the hell's
the difference
I went to the casino and I'll try again
yes you are yeah you're asking the
professional Gambler yeah ask the
responsible people in the room okay ask
Bubba ask santa like ask fans the rest
of them what do you guys think of that
move if I see something I really liked
with the money I'd probably thought
about you and he was and just say I'll
make more yeah oh rent and it was so
confident that he was going to make more
money he knew in his heart that he was
going to grow up
watch no but he didn't say how he was
going to make it he just said he was
gonna make it yeah so he said I'll make
sure
totally irresponsible I mean it's
totally impractical impractical totally
irresponsible but also understandable
you could have paid your bills and still
went and made more money and then got
the watch
it really is there I'm joking I don't
have any money
right Timex Rolex
[Laughter]
right
so maybe go buy the Rolex and see how it
goes
this one's about controlling your
temptations that friend
very carefully because it's going to
sound like something stupid but this is
actually true your hands are controlled
by your brain if you can't stop [ __ ]
drinking jerking off watching porn and
typing PornHub into your little keyboard
that is nobody's fault but yours is no
such thing as weak will your hands are
controlled by your brain use your brain
and control your [ __ ] hands control
your feet walk into the casino your
hands giving them but I don't have that
control some people have that
control it's not I'm not saying it's the
right answer control my feet from
walking into the country part of her
brain is not working right that's the
part of my brain that's not working but
I do what I want and I like to win money
I don't say oh I don't have it oh I
can't do it oh I'm not going I'll go and
if whatever it costs it costs unless
it's something completely out of my
league but I enjoy my life and I do what
I want to do it's not the right thing
but so what who gives a shift I actually
have my mother lecture me my mother was
lecturing me about art some of the women
I have children with she was like oh
well Tristan you know you could have
just had one woman and settle down had a
family and blah blah blah blah I was
like Mom they could have left at any
time they knew I was with a different
woman every single day and they stayed
and got pregnant and gave birth to a
child and they're very happy women but
they could have left
he can uh impregnate women but they
could have left what piece of [ __ ] is he
that he would let them leave and he has
kids you know what you're right he'll
get a vasectomy already and this way you
have sex with all the girls you want and
you only give the advice just give them
herpes not babies yeah right
he's having all of these children with
these girls which is fine he's
supporting them and all this other stuff
but how many kids is he gonna have 50 by
the time he's still Eddie Murphy is he
does all his girlfriends know about
Fielder girlfriends yes I think so yeah
but when he's with them it happens with
our conversation earlier when he's with
them he's with them for a year or two
years no no it's not like he's knocking
up random girls and he's like well you
can just leave that's not what it is but
if he's gonna raise the kid and be the
father he expects the woman relationship
girlfriends but they don't know that yes
they do and they get pregnant yeah well
then they want the money that happened
to the Lego Tristan what I've seen of
him like I think he's not all monster
he's got some good he's got some good
things he has no control over women he
has some controls
he has zero control zero control
because he doesn't want to sleep with
one woman forever he is like a woman
addict it's like addicted
he's a [ __ ] Master yeah this is one of
my friends snico he was doing a stream
with Tristan so I I messaged a question
for him to ask him during their live
stream can I sing before you click negro
is a big deal I'm a big sneaker fan I
call him a pumpkin and he gets mad that
I think he's a pumpkin
Sunny fast the guy who reacts to your
videos with uh his mom I don't I think
you know what I'm talking about he said
for someone who doesn't have a brother
like you do what do you recommend guy
does to make a true loyal Bond like that
I like that guy and his mom I do they're
great people I would say uh certainly
just be that kind of guy yourself be the
be the kind of moral person yourself
who's not going to tell on your friends
not going to snitch not going to cause
problems for your friends oh it's gonna
have their back in a fight or he's gonna
have their back in an argument if you
are that kind of guy you'll be surprised
you'll attract that type of P of people
what do you think of that surrounding
yourself with the right people
I think that's a successful person will
tell you you surround yourself with
people smarter than you are because
you'll learn and you'll grow a lot
faster than thinking you know everything
right yeah there's no argument there
there's nothing to even do not good
friends you want to face people isn't it
strange though how a lot of people
recognize that you need to surround
yourself with people more successful
than you and then people still hang out
with the same loser friends yeah smoke
and drink every day
smoking and drinking but hang out with
you I don't think you should ever forget
your friends that you grew up with that
maybe they don't have any good people
they're always my friends right that's
100 but you have to recognize that if
you want success you don't have to hang
out with them
because we will outgrow oh we have our
friends and then we have our own lives
but if any of my friends needed anything
I'd sell my jewelry for them oh my God
you go to the casino for them that's not
true she's still Tristan's jewelry and
sell it for that what would you guys
give Tristan Tate one to ten I'll give
him a ten ten ten ten seven seven
that I dislike him I think I like him
better than his brother what would you
give him Grandma I wasn't thrilled
itself you like him more than anything I
did that annoying I don't know if I like
him better or more I think they're both
cocky obnoxious in some way but yet
they're very but they get knives they're
very honest no but they're very honest
and I like the honesty yeah
I like it the success yeah yeah and it's
exaggerated whether we agree with it or
not like I'm going out with all these
women and yeah
[Laughter]
did you give him a reading no no comment
no comment all right thank you guys
[Music]
[Music]